[Música]
nos últimos dois anos e dez meses da
minha vida eu vivi inúmeras coisas mas
certamente as mais importantes foram os
nascimentos dos meus filhos
o benjamim e alice alice tem 40 dias e
ela tá aqui
o benjamin l se fazem parte de uma
estatística que no brasil não é positiva
eles nasceram de parto normal
e no brasil isso tem cada vez menos
adeptos
nós somos um dos países com o menor
índice de partos normais
se a gente considerar o que diz a oms
organização mundial da saúde eles
recomendam que as cesáreas não passem de
15% em relação ao total de partos no
brasil esse número chega a 55%
se a gente continua a considerar a rede
particular esse número chega a 85% e se
a gente for olhar só a maternidade onde
alice nasceu são só cinco por cento de
partos normais comparado com seis áreas
mas eu não tô aqui pra falar sobre uma
escolha da mulher entre ter parto normal
ou fazer cesárea não é esse o meu
objetivo mas eu quero falar sobre a
importância do trabalho de parto porque
essa escolha pela cesárea faz com que
muitas mulheres nem entrei em trabalho
de parto nem tenham essa sensação
e foi durante o trabalho de parto que eu
tive que passar pelas minhas maiores
dores e enfrentar os meus maiores medos
mas certamente foram essas dores e esses
medos que me tornar uma pessoa mais
forte e mais obstinada
o que eu me pergunto é se a gente tem
realmente conseguido enfrentar os nossos
medos e as nossas dores ea gente tem
conseguido encarar isso se a gente tem
tentado automatizar as nossas vidas
porque a tecnologia tem nos permitido
isso tem nos permitido automatizar
quando a gente está querendo realmente
usar o que é humano o que é o nosso
humano
a tecnologia tem feito tantas coisas que
têm feito a gente perdeu algumas
conexões quando é um exemplo
a google ea procter e gamble lançaram
uma fralda uma fralda inteligente é uma
fralda que avisa através de um
aplicativo quando o bb fez xixi fácil
assim a gente pode descobrir
só que o que a maternidade me fez
perceber é que tendo que entender o meu
filho olhar para o meu filho me conectar
com o meu filho que eu consigo também me
descobrir
será que se a gente começar a usar o
aplicativo para descobrir se o nenê fez
xixi a gente não vai perder uma
oportunidade incrível de fazer conexão
desse olhar de olhar para o outro e no
caso do recém nascido ainda mais forte
isso porque o recém nascido quando ele
nasce nem entende que ele é uma outra
pessoa e ainda se sente parte da mãe ea
mãe a mãe passa por um luto
o luto do pós-parto o uso por aquilo que
a gente deixou para trás o luto por
aquilo que a gente vai ter que deixar e
aí
enquanto a gente está passando por esse
momento a gente entra na rede social
e aí na rede social todo mundo está
feliz
todo mundo está vivendo aquela vida
perfeita linda maravilhosa só eu que não
e esse é o grande desafio porque a
tecnologia tem nos feito olhar para o
outro de uma maneira diferente tão
diferente que tem feito criar novos
medos muitos medos ansiedade depressão
fomo fubu fila filmes em alto fina peça
opportunity sabe aquela coisa de o
vizinho está fazendo uma coisa melhor
que eu ele teve uma oportunidade melhor
que eu se eu não olhar isso agora meu
deus o que vai acontecer comigo meu deus
meu deus meu deus eu tô perdendo está
acontecendo eu tô perdendo ou perdendo
eu
estou perdendo o tempo inteiro ea
tecnologia têm nos feito desconectá
quando justamente a gente teria
oportunidade de maior conexão com será
que o próximo passo depois a fralda
inteligente
será que é botar dinheiro na carteira
virtual do nosso filho para ele poder
pegar o uberaba para voltar da festa
mas quando o nosso pai buscava na festa
era sobre o que era sobre tecnologia ou
era sobre conexão era sobre a carona ou
sobre saber com quem a gente tava onde
era festa como a gente estava saindo da
festa será que a tecnologia vai nos
fazer perder esse olhar não molhar
realmente para quem a gente é a
tecnologia tem nos feito idealizar criar
perfis que são irreais e que a gente
nunca vai conseguir alcançar um estudo
recente feito por uma agência inglesa
chamados terreiros offline disse que o
instagram é possivelmente um dos
aplicativos de uma das tecnologias mais
propensas a gerar pessoas com ansiedade
e depressão com problemas com o próprio
corpo e por que isso porque a gente só
idealiza ea gente não vive aquilo que é
real e eu tô falando tudo isso porque eu
trabalho com tecnologia é o meu dia a
dia não é só meu dia a dia eu vivo disso
minha empresa de tecnologia eu tenho que
vender tecnologia para os outros mas é
justamente por eu ter que vender
tecnologia para os outros e olhar a
maternidade que eu fiz essa junção e
entende que a gente está perdendo a mão
que a gente está exagerando um estudo
chamado bem mas céu apontou que 86 por
cento das pessoas entrevistadas disseram
que elas usam o celular enquanto elas
estão falando com outras pessoas com os
amigos com os familiares mas meu deus a
gente não está mais nem prestando
atenção em quem está do nosso lado
a gente usa o celular demais e isso não
é só uma impressão é realidade é
estatística
o brasil um dos cinco países que lidera
ranking de uso de celular ea tecnologia
fez e faz muito pela gente com certeza
ainda vai fazer muito
só que se a gente perder a oportunidade
de olhar para o nosso humano essencial
nada do que a tecnologia tem para nos
proporcionar vai ser válido
a equipa é uma gigante do varejo e eles
criaram percebendo essa coisa de a gente
não conseguir se conectar uma campanha
chamada disconnect reconnect foi uma
campanha de natal agora do natal de 2018
é justamente essa foi a provocação as
pessoas não sabiam o que tinha
acontecido na vida dos pais mas sabiam
quem era blogueira o youtube mais famosa
naquele momento o thomas friedman aquele
que escreveu o mundo é plano ele disse
que a tecnologia diminui as distâncias
entre os países e com certeza a diminuir
as distâncias entre os países ou não é
verdade que a gente consegue hoje
conectar com o mundo inteiro
mas será que a gente não tá esquecendo
de conectar com quem está do lado
achando que a gente pode conectar com
quem está do outro lado
quando eu fiz a minha faculdade de
direito eu estudei uma coisa chamada
alienação parental alienação parental é
aquele conceito onde um pai manipula
psicologicamente o filho pra que ele é
ignora ou seja hostil em relação ao
outro o que a maternidade me fez
perceber que a gente está criando um
outro conceito de alienação parental que
aquele pai que não consegue enxergar um
filho que não consegue olhar para o lado
que está tão conectado vivendo uma vida
que não existe vivendo a vida do outro
que não consegue olhar para sua própria
cria conectar com o seu próprio filho e
uma mãe
uma mãe chora uma mãe chora
o pai chora essa desconexão
tem uma frase que diz que o bebê chora o
que a mãe cala
e é justamente porque a gente tá
perdendo essa conexão ea gente não
consegue nem pôr para fora aquilo que
nos angustia e aí quando chega de noite
e começam as cólicas
a gente corre pro google para tentar
entender o google o que eu faço com meu
filho agora ele está chorando ele está
com cólica resolve a cólica pra mim o
google não resolve
e aí a gente pega o aplicativo e põe
aquele som de secador de cabelo para ver
se o secador de cabelo vai então
resolver o choro ea gente descobre que é
só um colinho aconchegante que pode
fazer o choro pará não tem aplicativo
que faça a tecnologia fez ela faz
ela vai fazer muito ainda por nós mas
ela não vai conseguir resolver aquilo
que precisa do ser humano
aic a quando fez essa campanha também
desconectou do dia 24 de dezembro de
2018 até 1º de janeiro de 2019 e
suspenderam todas as atividades deles
nas mídias nas redes sociais
será que a gente está promovendo também
momentos de desconexões de desligar de
olhar pra gente mesmo de olhar por nós
humano essencial e descobrir quais são
as nossas angústias as nossas dores os
nossos medos as nossas fraquezas e como
a gente vai buscar respostas para tudo
isso
a verdade é que a tecnologia já levou o
homem para a lua mas ela nunca vai fazer
com que alguém que não teve um parto
normal consegue entender como é da vida
alguém da forma mais natural possível
a tecnologia ainda pode fazer muito pela
gente ela fez ela vai fazer
ela pode fazer uma série de coisas ela
pode curar ela pode trazer curas para
doenças ela pode imprimir órgãos ela
pode fazer recrutamento e seleção ela
pode fazer barba cabelo e bigode
lavar passar a tecnologia pode até fazer
a gente tem uma casa inteligente mas a
tecnologia não vai fazer com que a gente
tenha um lar
não adianta a gente viver numa sociedade
cheia de conteúdo mas vazia de
significado
a verdade é que quando a tecnologia
fizer ainda mais do que ela já tem feito
por nós
a gente vai ter que voltar a fazer uma
coisa que a gente tá esquecendo de fazer
quando a tecnologia fizer tanto ou tão
pouco talvez por nós
a gente vai ter que começar a viver
obrigada
[Aplausos]